imagine you're on your last flask of
healing searching for a checkpoint in
the snowy wastes instead you're met with
a dramatic scene a circular arena with
an enormous glaive planted in its centre
could it be he turned to leave but a
Mista gate blocks your way from behind
you hear the chilling words you need a
glue stick coming here and when you turn
back the enormous weapon is now in the
hands of clave master Hadiya the boss
bar appears the music begins and your
life is about to end it's what I might
say if I had any new Eldon ring
information to share with you instead
I'm just making this up I doubt you
could even imagine that we'd be here
four months ago but there's barely been
any news at all Oh
Eldon ring you think someone would say
something about it but instead our hopes
have just been shattered with every new
convention games come no trailers tokyo
game show
nothing brazil game show but look up the
reddit and you'd think it would be dead
right but it burns it's on fire with
posts about Eldon ring full of users so
desperate for news that they've actually
started to pretend that the game is
already out there's a huge post ranking
fictional bosses from easiest to hardest
folks are discussing their favorite boss
music and don't even get them started on
glaive master hoodies sweep into heavy
attack combo glaive master ho dere was
the first boss they created I think and
it seems like no one knows how to beat
him but I do just like you kill any meme
the way to beat this meme boss is to
make him popular so by bringing him to
my audience I hereby claim that I'm the
first to defeat blade master who did all
of this
fake law and fake bosses got me thinking
since it's unlikely we'll get Eldon ring
news until the game Awards in December
and since everyone's going hollow
waiting let's do something to pass the
time earlier this year we ran the
prosthetic art challenge for sekito
which was really fun and today I'm
excited to announce the first art
challenge for Eldon Ring
it's going to be an effort to give form
to fictional bosses but they have to be
inspired by regional folklore and the
limited information on Eldon ring that
we already have if you're interested in
competing tune in to the end of the
video where I'm going to go over the
finer details and if you're not
interested
keep listening because there is still a
ton of Elden ring news I haven't shared
on this channel yet coming soon the
prize pool for this challenge is higher
this time it's going to be two thousand
US dollars and it's going to be split
across the top ten participants as shown
on screen the reason I can fund this out
of my own pocket is because you guys
have been insanely supportive of the
sponsorship and merchandise stuff that
I've been doing like insanely supportive
so thank you speaking of which this is
your last chance to buy fate my limited
edition
Elden ring inspired much I've added 48
more hours to the listing and then this
red-haired variant is gone forever so
check it out in the description below
all the way back in June I penned a
video about Eldon ring that was based on
the trailer but a few days later more
information dropped in interviews and in
leaks despite what I said earlier
there's a lot here you might have missed
and there's even more to speculate on
first we have confirmation via IGN that
our character will be able to traverse
the world on a horse
if mounts are required then it really
does confirm that the scale of the world
is going to be huge because we need the
mount to traverse it this sort of scale
isn't seen in any other from software
games this could explain why the game
seems to be eating up more development
time than usual incidentally these were
some of the first leaks that we received
and these leaks also suggested that we'd
be traveling to distant kingdoms in
order to acquire their special power
hopefully the existence of different
kingdoms implies that the game will be a
truly open world from the very start I
feel like so many open-world games make
the mistake of designing these enormous
worlds only to put the character on
Rails often we're restricted by the
story or were restricted by the
increased difficulty in late-game areas
but since from unusually restricted by
story or scaling difficulty I can
imagine their open world being closer to
something like breadth of the wilds
design with areas that you can tackle in
any order and with every area having its
own self-contained story another common
feature of open-world games are really
big populated towns but miyazaki admits
that creating a more open game is a big
challenge for us if we were to add towns
on top of that it would become a bit too
much so we decided to create an open
world style game focused on what we're
best at and what they're best at is
definitely not populated heavily
voice-acted towns so villages will be
the dark dungeon like ruins that you've
come to expect from us usually when
games build really populated towns into
them they often serve as a sort of
reprieve from travel and combat they're
a chance for your character to chat and
trade with NPCs and also to develop the
story a little bit more the closest
parallel to something like this in from
games are their hub worlds like violent
crime which give you a break from the
endless death in the overworld
but if Elden rings open world has you
doing things like gathering resources or
finding traders navigating or just
looking for non-combat secrets then man
that's plenty of relaxation for me I
always get kind of bored chatting to
NPC's in towns so I'm not sad to see
this go but I do wonder what's their
excuse going to be for everyone in the
world being dead again maybe a sort of
Ragnarok perhaps so while Miyazaki
considers the gameplay to be in the same
genre as Dark Souls he also goes on to
state that with a larger world new
systems and action mechanics inevitably
become necessary in that sense I think
that Eldon ring is a more natural
evolution of Dark Souls the more
extensive world will form the base of
Eldon rinks gameplay and its mechanics
are designed with that type of
environment in mind that's pretty vague
but let me try to contextualize his
statements by using other open-world
games as examples so when he says that
new systems will become necessary as a
result of the open world maybe he's
talking about things like preparation
mechanics that make use of resources in
the world like alchemy in The Witcher 3
which lets you prepare for certain types
of combat by giving you certain types of
buffs he could be talking about a
crafting system where you create tools
and weapons from the resources around
you like in horizon zero dawn or even
weapon maintenance systems like in Metro
Exodus he could even be talking about
survival mechanics where the world
itself is your enemy and is the gameplay
and you might need to take the weather
or your hunger or body warmth into
account I suppose these are examples of
the world itself forming the
quote-unquote base of Elden rings
gameplay as miyazaki says miyazaki goes
on to say that larger environments will
add more variation to battles so this
reminds me the most of breath of the
wild again where you can use the
environment in creative ways to take out
groups of enemies you can roll rocks
down into their encampments you can
steal their weapons while they sleep so
that they have nothing to fight you with
you can even do crazy things like giving
them metal weapons in a storm so that
they get struck by lightning when they
pick them up another example might be in
horizon zero dawn where you can set
traps ahead of difficult encounters I
love this kind of stuff and having more
control of the world around you in Elden
ring it could be huge another
fundamental difference here is that
we're going to be mounted a lot of the
time so combat must be changing to suit
the increased movement speed of us and
our enemies so when we look at other
games with mounted combat in an open
world it usually consists of maneuvering
your mount for a while
and then there's a brief clash with a
well-timed strike and then you maneuver
again and clash and go on and on in
reality a lot of this time is usually
spent sprinting past your enemy missing
and getting stuck on a tree or some
terrain for me the best mounted combat
moments usually come when some sort of
slow motion or archery is involved but I
generally end up hating the whole
mounted combat experience but if anyone
can remove the awkwardness of mounted
combat it's from software so I fully
expect them to innovate in this space
moving away from combat
Elden ring is said to go beyond simply
bringing new twists to the formula like
blood-borne and secular did now with a
largest scale says Miyazaki there will
be more freedom and depth to exploration
which I hope means there's going to be
more secrets and even side quests maybe
that aren't combat based look back at
Circulo and think about all the new
verticality they added to that game you
can jump you can grapple swimming was
incredible and actually you have the
feeling that these mechanics might have
been a sort of beta test for what will
surely be an Eldon ring as well as for
navigation in Elden ring my only hope is
that exploration actually requires you
to engage with the world around you one
of the worst trends in open-world games
I think waypoints and there's always
this focus on that little arrow that
tells you where to go next and as a
result you sort of stop taking in the
world around you we've never seen what a
map function looks like in a from game
and I'm came to see their take on it
because you can't design cooler ways of
interacting with the world around you to
sort of figure out where you are and
where you're going
finally Miyazaki hopes that the world
and law can now be displayed on a
grander scale and with genuine distance
between locations now the world should
certainly feel more real and as for the
law well we'll have to talk about george
RR martin
that one of the law we currently know
very little except that the olden ring
once served as the rules and the rhythm
of the world as a parallel to this to
help you understand just think about how
the age of fire worked in Dark Souls
it was always rising and falling but it
was never-ending
and whatever the Eldon ring is it sounds
like a similar logic of the world but
now it's been shattered and it seems
like characters now forced to survive in
a post Eldon Ring world a world that
Miyazaki says will showcase the will of
humanity so everything that occurred
before this shattering aka the law was
actually written by George Martin he
wrote about a time the player wasn't
directly involved in and then passed
that story on the from software team who
go on to describe his writing as a sort
of guide book for the world's law they
say it's similar to having a Dungeon
Master's Handbook in a tabletop RPG
Miyazaki says it was a fantastic
collaboration as we weren't restricted
by each other yet we were still
influenced by each other's work by
having him write about a time that the
player isn't directly involved in he is
free to unleash his creativity in the
way that he likes furthermore as from
software we didn't want to create a more
linear and story-driven experience for
Eldon ring so both issues could be
solved by having Martin write about the
world's history instead the player will
be able to learn about Martin's
mythology through exploration confirmed
Miyazaki we're known for letting the
player explore the games law through
fragments of environmental storytelling
and this time around
Martin's story is what you'll be trying
to unravel the period that the player
actually explores is still connected to
the old times
so as you slowly discover why the world
has become the way it is you'll learn
more about Martin's mythology as well so
getting towards the end now any extra
information we have at this point in the
video is only really attainable from
leaks and when it comes to leaks in the
past few months there's only really one
that's worth its salt
in May there was this large post that
was made on the reset era forums by a
renowned user called omnipotent who has
accurately leaked details about from
software games in the past if you want
to read his full post it's in the
description but here are the safest
takeaways from what they had to say take
this with a grain of salt of course
according to the leaks the game is
likely to be high fantasy which means
it's quite fantastical and not grounded
in reality
it also seems like there's going to be a
very high likelihood the game will have
PvP creative builds RPG elements and a
sort of variable experience depending on
how you build your character these are
things that Romney says will foster good
and I quote YouTube content even goes
and spells out Scotland at one point
which is a region with folklore that is
rarely explored in games and this is
basically going to be the basis of the
art competition seeing how we could
bring folklore from this region to life
he also seems to make a few nods towards
the same sort of vibe that de Rosnay
gives off with a world that is just out
of view and yet present all the same
think fairies and other whimsical yet
sinister beings
it could even be inspired by William
sharps poetry like dare asana was he
says that there is so much to dig into
and search for perfect for people who
like to explore and discover these
worlds law hounds and solitary soldiers
there's plenty of unearthed knowledge to
write your paragraphs of theories about
that's good and he actually puts capital
letters on unnerved knowledge so maybe
he's suggesting that there is a sort of
old world to uncover or maybe
underground labyrinths to explore
towards the end he even mentioned some
themes that are common with Vikings like
runes and cello horns and there was even
some overlap between Viking and Celtic
cultures at some point in history so it
does all seem to be coming together in
that region of course like all lakes
we're going to have to wait and see
if this is validated in December before
we take it all too seriously but I'd
like where this is heading and finally
he says this journey doesn't end with e3
this is only the beginning so don't
expect to be fully satiated just yet
but I hope this hype train will carry us
there and back again rain or shine
rain or shine maybe he's referring to a
weather system but I am more concerned
that he says that the hype train might
carry us all the way back to e3 if this
is true then the game might actually
have a later release date than we
expected because I was pretty sure they
were going to show gameplay at Gamescom
and then I was pretty sure they were
going to show it at tokyo game show but
now i'm pretty sure they're going to
show gameplay at the game Awards in
December hopefully I'm not wrong again
as for a release date the earliest
possible would be March 2020 as that's
when from usually releases their games
and it's the end of the fiscal year in
Japan however their trailer releases
have been later than expected usually
we're a bit further along at this point
and there aren't many big conventions at
all really that are left to promote the
game at between now and March
additionally the game scope is way
bigger than recent titles so I honestly
wouldn't be surprised if Elden ring was
the first title in a while to buck the
trend and it might actually be released
later in the year we should all be
prepared for that at least but for now
let's move on to the art competition
it's gonna be something that can keep us
sane and entertained if we do end up
having to wait a really long time the
goal of this competition is to design
and draw a boss and the only requirement
really is that your inspiration must be
drawn from the folklore that Elden ring
is rumored to be inspired by it
so that's Scandinavian Nordic folklore
Gaelic folklore Irish folklore Celtic
mythology or even Scottish mythology of
course Elden ring might not end up
inspired by these things at all but it's
a start
and all of these places have incredible
creatures and themes and stories and
whether you choose just one of these
sources or a mixture for your boss
design is up to you in the description
I've listed some reading material to
sort of start you off but I encourage
you to go beyond this and look on your
own as well once you've chosen your
inspiration and you've drawn your piece
send it to me with a bit of a written
description two things I'd like you to
write in your email first tell me what
folklore that you were actually inspired
by and second tell me a little bit about
your boss fight tell me for example
what's its name
where does the fight take place does the
fight have dialog does it have phases
law does the boss have weaknesses does
it make use of the open world in some
way if you decide to draw a background
environment is this where the fight
takes place just give me some
information don't worry about answering
all these questions I just want you to
give me some idea of what the fight is
like and how it reflects your boss
design if you're still looking for more
inspiration bear in mind that I have two
videos on Eldon Ring now there's a
cinematic where two characters in it
have sort of prosthetic arms there's two
knights in this trailer that have red
hair they're all high fantasy styled
Knights these are all sort of trends
that you can maybe pull inspiration from
as well so go watch the trailer go watch
my videos he'll go on the Eldon Ring
subreddit and look at some of the bosses
that people have just made up and posted
about I'm sure these people would be ok
with you bringing their ideas to life as
long as you credit them in your email
I've linked some really good comments
from the subreddit down below assuming
this contest goes well at least the top
10 winners will be featured in a video
and there will be special mention to
other contestants as well prize
distribution is as follows on screen and
it will be delivered via PayPal you have
until midnight on the 23rd of November
PST to email your art to Eldon ring
challenge at gmail.com remember twinks
a written description of the folklore
you were inspired by tell me how the
bossfight works list your artist
portfolio social media and also your
paypal address in case you win if you
have any questions don't email them
instead head over to my discord and go
to the Eldon Ring FAQ and see if your
question has already been asked if it
hasn't you can ask the question in the
text channel below it thank you so much
for your interest I think this is gonna
be fun if you're not an artist maybe
share this competition with an artist
that you know and good luck see you in a
month